This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. It's the end of the year and time for our annual mini stories episodes. Mini stories are quick hit stories that were maybe pitched to us from someone in the audience or something interesting we saw on Twitter or just a cool tidbit that we found in our research that just got stuck in our heads and wouldn't come out. But they didn't quite warrant the full episode treatment for whatever reason. There also this great opportunity for us to get to know the non-scripted version of the fine people who work on this show, and as the person who gets to interview them, that is my favorite part of this. We have some real charmer's on staff. We'll have stories of mysterious ice boats,
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马尔斯。年终岁尾，又到了我们每年一度的迷你故事特辑时间。迷你故事是一些短小精悍的故事，也许是听众向我们推荐的，也许我们在推特上看到的趣事，或者是我们在资料搜集时发现并一直在脑子里挥之不去的小八卦。但出于种种原因，它们还不足以撑起一整集的篇幅。这也是一个绝佳的机会，让我们去了解本节目幕后优秀工作人员们不按剧本发挥的一面，而作为采访他们的人，这是我最喜欢的部分。我们员工里有几个非常迷人的人。我们将为大家讲述关于神秘冰船的故事，
green ruins, sacked dresses, steampunk violins, and a little update from a couple of the notable city flags that have been redesigned around the country. It's going to be fun. First up is senior producer, Katie Mingle. So, okay, we're going to start out by meeting Denise. Hi, my name is Denise Boniface, and I own Aquanux diving in Rocky Mountain House, Alberta, Canada. Yeah, so Denise is from Alberta, Canada, where she owns a scuba diving company. And Alberta, as you may know, is not a coastal province. So if you're scuba diving in Alberta, you're doing it in lakes.
绿色废墟、面粉袋连衣裙、蒸汽朋克小提琴，以及全国各地几面引人注目的城市旗帜重新设计后的最新进展。这将会非常有趣。首先登场的是资深制作人凯蒂·明格尔。那么，好吧，我们要从认识丹妮丝开始。嗨，我叫丹妮丝·博尼法斯，我在加拿大艾伯塔省落基山ハウス经营 Aquanux 潜水公司。是的，所以丹妮丝来自加拿大艾伯塔省，她在那里经营一家水肺潜水公司。如你所知，艾伯塔省并不是一个沿海省份。所以如果你在艾伯塔省潜水，你只能在湖里潜。
They're cold, they're dark, they're murky, they're kind of creepy. Sounds delightful. Sometimes. So there's this one lake called Lake Patricia. Surrounded by mountains, it's right in a mountain valley, very, very remote. And if you find the right spot on the lake
它们冰冷、黑暗、浑浊、有点诡异。听起来真令人愉快。有时是这样的。所以有一个叫帕特里夏湖的湖。四周环绕着群山，它就位于一个山谷中，非常非常偏远。如果你在湖里找到合适的地方
and dive about 30 feet down, you'll find a shipwreck. It doesn't really look like a ship. It looks like there's a pile of lumber that's all broken up and laying there. And then there's a lot of refrigeration coils. What are the refrigeration coils for? We're going to get to that, but just, okay, for now, so you make your way down sort of through this murky darkness, this like pile of lumber and debris. 50 feet, 60 feet. And then you'll find a plaque.
然后潜水大约 30 英尺深，你会发现一艘沉船。它看起来其实不太像一艘船。它看起来像是有一堆断裂的木材堆放在那里。然后还有很多制冷盘管。制冷盘管是做什么用的？我们一会儿会讲到，不过现在，好吧，你要穿过这种浑浊的黑暗，这堆木材和碎片。下潜 50 英尺，60 英尺。然后你会发现一块牌匾。
Oh. Right? This is where her home and gets excited. It's pitch dark, but if you shine a light on it, you can read it and Denise has read it. Plot says operations have a cut. A secret World War II project involving the use of ice and ship construction. The special built January to April 1943 was a prototype. Some more information contacts the Canadian Park Service
哦。对吧？这就是她的家乡变得令人兴奋的地方。里面漆黑一片，但如果你用手电筒照着它，你就能读懂它，而丹妮丝已经读过了。上面写着，哈巴谷计划行动。一个绝密的二战项目，涉及在船舶建造中使用冰。这艘特制的船于 1943 年 1 月至 4 月建造，是一个原型。如需更多信息，请联系加拿大公园管理局
jasker. Wow, so there's like a hyperlink in the bottom of a lake. WWW dot, yeah there's a QR code. Okay, so there's so many things about this plaque that I love. I love that it's at the bottom of a lake I love the part where it says for more info contact the Canadian Park Service because it sort of implies you could just Dumble across this while like strolling at the bottom of a Canadian lake And then I actually I asked Denise that and she was like, yeah, you could because there's a lot of people that tied in this lake but of course the most intriguing part of the plaque is the part about the secret World War II project
贾斯珀。哇，所以湖底就像有一个超链接。网址，是的，还有一个二维码。好吧，这块牌匾有很多地方我都非常喜欢。我喜欢它在湖底，我喜欢上面写着“欲知详情，请联系加拿大公园管理局”的部分，因为这听起来好像你漫步在加拿大湖底时就会偶然撞见这个。然后实际上，我问过丹妮丝，她说是的，你确实会，因为有很多人在这个湖里潜水，但当然，这块牌匾最引人入胜的部分是关于二战绝密项目的那部分，
involving the use of ice in ship construction. So what was that about? So, okay, so in the early 1940s during World War II, German submarines, or U-boats as they were called, were basically wreaking havoc on allied ships in the Atlantic Ocean, just sinking them left and right. And so eventually this person named Admiral Mount Batten goes to Winston Churchill and he's like, we have to do something about this. And I think I know what this solution is. A giant, unsinkable aircraft carrier sized ship made of ice. Of course.
即在船舶建造中使用冰。那到底是是怎么回事？所以，好吧，在 20 世纪 40 年代初的二战期间，德国潜水艇（即所谓的 U 型潜艇）在大西洋上对盟军船只大肆破坏，一艘接一艘地击沉它们。因此，最终这个人，路易斯·蒙巴顿海军上将找到温斯顿·丘吉尔，对他说，我们必须对此采取行动。我想我知道解决方案是什么了。一艘由冰制成的、巨大且永不沉没的航空母舰大小的船。当然。
Right. And actually, Churchill is intrigued. Like, it sounds like one of those far-fetched ideas that kind of gets floated during times war, but never actually gets built, except for this really did get built, or at least a prototype of it got built, and that is the shipwreck at the bottom of Patricia Lake, and that's what the plaque commemorates. Wow. So what in the world made Admiral Mountbatten think that an unsinkable ship should be made of ice. Yeah, so like, what the hell? Yeah, yeah, okay. It's fair enough.
对吧。事实上，丘吉尔很感兴趣。这听起来像是战争时期流传的那种异想天开的想法，但实际上从未真正建造过，除了这个真的被建造了，或者至少它的原型被建造了，那就是帕特里夏湖底的沉船，这也是那块牌匾所纪念的东西。哇。那么，究竟是什么让蒙巴顿海军上将认为一艘永不沉没的船应该用冰来建造呢？是的，所以，搞什么鬼？对吧，对吧，好吧。这倒也合情合理。
Okay, so steel and aluminum were in really short supplies. So that was a big thing. They were actively looking for alternatives. And then the second thing is that they, they hoped that this ice ship would be so dense that it would basically be indestructible. And what made them think that ice would be indestructible because it doesn't seem like that. Right.
好吧，当时钢和铝的供应非常短缺。所以这是一个大问题。他们一直在积极寻找替代品。第二个原因是，他们希望这艘冰船能够足够厚密，以至于基本上坚不可摧。是什么让他们觉得冰会是坚不可摧的呢？因为看起来并不像那样。对吧。
Yeah, it actually, it wasn't just plain ice. They were, they were going to build these ships out of a mixture of ice and sawdust called piecrete, named after its inventor, a guy named Jeffrey Pike. So if you mixed sort mixed water and wood chips together and then froze it, it made the ice really, really strong. And so this guy, Jeffrey Pike, he invented not only Pyecrete, but he came up with the idea of building a ship out of it. And then he got that idea to Admiral Mountbatten.
是的，实际上，它不仅仅是普通的冰。他们打算用一种冰和木屑的混合物来建造这些船，这种混合物被称为派克特（Pycrete），是以它的发明者杰弗里·派克（Jeffrey Pike）的名字命名的。因此，如果你把水和木屑混合在一起然后冷冻，就会使冰变得非常非常坚固。所以这个叫杰弗里·派克的家伙，不仅发明了派克特，还想出了用它造船的主意。然后他把这个想法告诉了蒙巴顿海军上将。
So the ships would be built from blocks of Pycrete, and then there would basically be pipes with coolant running through the whole thing. To keep it ice. Yeah, so that's the refrigerator coils that Denise saw at the bottom of the lake. And Pycrete really was this like incredibly strong and dense mixture, and there's this amazing anecdote in this story
因此，这些船将由派克特冰块建造，然后在整个船体中基本上都会有冷却剂管道通过。为了保持它是冰。是的，这就是丹妮丝在湖底看到的制冷盘管。派克特确实是一种非常坚固且密集的混合物，这个故事中有一个非常棒的轶事，
where Admiral Mount Baton, who, again, is not the inventor of Pycrate, but he's like the main kind of evangelist for this idea. And he was so hype about it that he brings a piece of Pycrate to a meeting. This is a meeting in which they were trying to convince the Americans. So the British were trying to convince the Americans, so the British were trying to convince the Americans to get on board this crazy ice ship plan.
蒙巴顿海军上将再次出场，他并不是派克特的 pentru 发明者，但他就像这个想法的主要传道者。他对这个主意狂热至极，以至于带着一块派克特去参加一个会议。这是一场他们试图说服美国人的会议。因此，英国人试图说服美国人，英国人试图说服美国人加入这个疯狂的冰船计划。
So he brings a block of piecrete to the meeting along with a regular block of ice. And at some point, he does this demonstration where he takes out his revolver and he shoots the regular ice and it splinters into a thousand little pieces and then he shoots the piecrete and The bullet bounces off the piecrete and actually sort of ricochets into the leg of one of his colleagues And like successful test it's actually like declared a total success and and they're all thumbs up, green light, full speed head. And yeah, they decided to go forward with this crazy plan. Winston Churchill signs off on it.
因此，他带了一块派克特去开会，同时还带了一块普通的冰块。在某个时候，他做了一个演示，他掏出左轮手枪，朝普通的冰块开了一枪，冰块碎成了成千上万的小碎片，然后他朝派克特开枪，子弹从派克特上弹开，实际上反弹到了他其中一个同事的腿上。测试非常成功，它实际上被宣布为完全成功，大家纷纷竖起大拇指，一路绿灯，全速前进。是的，他们决定推进这个疯狂的计划。温斯顿·丘吉尔批准了这项计划。
I'm not sure what all Americans signed off on it, but the Americans said, we'll help you do this. And then I guess at some point, they also got Canadians involved because they end up building this prototype on this little lake in Alberta, Canada. Lake Patricia. Yes, Lake Patricia. And they name it Project Habakkuk after a Bible verse. And I think the verse is pretty interesting, marvelously, for I am working a work in your days, which
我不知道具体有哪些美国人批准了它，但美国人说，我们会帮你做这件事。然后我想在某个时候，他们也让加拿大人参与进来了，因为他们最终在加拿大艾伯塔省的一个小湖上建造了这个原型。帕特里夏湖。是的，帕特里夏湖。他们根据《圣经》中的一节经文将其命名为哈巴谷计划。我想这节经文非常有趣，奇妙的是，因为我在你们的日子里做了一件事，
you will not believe though it'd be told to you. Basically like the Bible verse that's like, we are building a crazy f***ing thing. And Habakkuk apparently was the name of a Hebrew prophet, which I certainly never knew. And then the prototype itself was built by Canadian conscientious objectors who didn't know what they were building and who had opted for alternative service jobs. And they were like given this job and not really told that it actually was... A worship. Yeah, for the war. and not really told that it actually was. A worship.
即使告诉你们，你们也不会相信。基本上就像《圣经》经文说的那样，我们在建造一个疯狂的鬼东西。哈巴谷显然是一个希伯来先知的名字，我以前绝对不知道。然后原型本身是由加拿大拒绝服兵役者建造的，他们不知道自己在建造什么，并且选择了替代性服兵役工作。他们被分配了这项工作，并没有被真正告知这其实是……一艘战舰。是的，为了战争。并没有被真正告知这其实是……一艘战舰。
Yeah, for the war. So, in just a few months, they built a prototype of this ship, but it ended up being harder to build and more expensive than they thought. And by the time the prototype was ready, the war had kind of moved on. Like, they were figuring out how to build the atomic bomb.
是的，为了战争。所以，在短短几个月内，他们就建造了这个船只的原型，但结果发现它比想象中更难建造，也更昂贵。当原型准备好时，战争的形势已经发生了变化。比如，他们正在弄清楚如何制造原子弹。
They figured out how to mass produce smaller aircraft carriers. And in the end, they basically scrapped the project and ultimately let it sink into the bottom of Lake Patricia. And as we know, you can still see it there today. Well, the coolest thing about diving the helicopter is being able to say that you don't have a helicopter. Like, it is cool to dive it, and it's nice to see it once, but to dive it too many times, it's not that interesting, but I'm not a word to it,
他们弄清楚了如何批量生产较小的航空母舰。最后，他们基本上放弃了这个项目，并最终让它沉入帕特里夏湖底。正如我们所知，你今天仍然可以在那里看到它。嗯，潜水直升机最酷的事情就是能够说你没有直升机。比如，去潜水确实很酷，看一次也挺好，但潜水太多次就没那么有趣了，不过我对此无话可说，
but that doesn't really help you, pretty well, and does it. Yeah, so apparently, like, if you build a ship out of ice, it just sort of like turns into nothing. There's slush at the bottom of the ocean. Yeah, just. And if you've seen it once, you've seen it enough. That's fine.
但这其实帮不了你什么，对吧。是的，所以显然，如果你用冰造一艘船，它就会化成虚无。海底只有雪泥。是的，就是这样。如果你看过一次，你就看够了。没关系。
That's awesome. I love that story. Special thanks to Debbie Schneiderman, who sent in the tip about Project Habacook. She actually sent it in response to the mini-stories episode that we did last year. So if you also have a mini-story suggestion, we do read them. Reach us through the contact page at 99pi.org. Next up, producer Emmett Fitzgerald.
太棒了。我喜欢这个故事。特别感谢黛比·施耐德曼（Debbie Schneiderman），她提供了关于哈巴谷计划的线索。她其实是在回应我们去年做的迷你故事特辑时发来这个线索的。所以如果你也有迷你故事的建议，我们确实会阅读。通过 99pi.org 上的联系页面联系我们。接下来是制作人埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）。
All right, are you ready? Yeah, you should just try. I don't know what you're gonna do. Okay, so this is a story about a ruin. It's probably the most famous ruin, maybe, in the world. The Roman Colosseum. Oh, cool. You ever been?
好了，准备好了吗？是的，你直接试一下就行。我不知道你要做什么。好吧，这是一个关于废墟的故事。这可能是世界上最著名的废墟。罗马斗兽场。哦，酷。你去过吗？
I have never been. I've also never been. But you can picture it, right? Absolutely, you can picture it. You can picture white columns kind of dusty, denuded of all life, and it just looks like a classic ruin. Right, so what color would you say to white, maybe brown, off kind of old sand, colored stone? Totally. I think that's like, yeah, that's sort of the image we have of ruins, but I was on Twitter the other day and I found this kind of amazing thread that featured
我从来没去过。我也从来没去过。但你能想象出来，对吧？绝对能想象出来。你能想象出白色的柱子，有点尘土飞扬，褪去了所有的生命力，它看起来就像一个经典的废墟。没错，那你觉得是什么颜色？白色，也许是棕色，有点旧沙子颜色的石头？完全同意。我觉得就是这样，是的，这就是我们对废墟的印象，但前几天我在推特上看到了一个非常棒的帖子，里面有
all these paintings from the 19th century. And the Colosseum is totally green. It's like this, this greenhouse covered in vines and plants and all this different plant life. And it was a thread put together by this guy named Paul Cooper. He's a novelist and a PhD researcher at the University of East Anglia, and he studies the history of ruins. And he says that, you know, until the middle of the 19th century, the Coliseum was, yeah, I was totally overrun with plants. There were trees
所有这些 19 世纪的画作。斗兽场完全是绿色的。它就像一个被藤蔓、植物和所有不同植物生命覆盖的温室。这是由一个叫保罗·库珀（Paul Cooper）的人整理的帖子。他是东英吉利亚大学的小说家和博士研究员，他研究废墟的历史。他说，直到 19 世纪中叶，斗兽场确实，被植物完全淹没了。到处都是树木、灌木和藤蔓在生长。而且，你知道，所有这些艺术家和诗人都会把斗兽场描述为一个郁郁葱葱的温室。查尔斯·狄更斯参观了这处废墟，并说，写到了它被绿色植物覆盖的墙壁和拱门。在 1850 年代，这位英国植物学家，一个名叫理查德·迪肯（Richard Deacon）的人，决定对斗兽场进行一次植物普查，对生长在废墟上的所有植物进行分类编目。嗯，他发现了非常多的植物。在crumbling ruins（ crumbling ruins应为崩塌的废墟）中生长着 400 多种植物。这就是保罗·库珀。就是这个人，整理了推特帖子。
and shrubs and vines growing everywhere. And, you know, like all these artists and poets would write about the Coliseum as this verdant greenhouse Charles Dickens visited the ruin and said, you know, wrote about its walls and arches overrun with green. And in the 1850s, this British botanist, a man named Richard Deacon, decides to do a botanical survey of the Coliseum, cataloging all of the plants growing on the run. Well, he found a great many plants. So over 400 species that were growing among the crumbling ruins. So that's Paul Cooper. That's the fellow, but together, the Twitter threat.
没错。他告诉我这个叫理查德·迪肯的家伙发现的所有不同植物。56 种草本植物、柏树和冬青树。是的，种类真是多得不可思议。迪肯的书展现出来的是，对这片正在崩塌的景观进行了极其诗意的描述，它变成了一个品种繁多的野蛮生长的花园。书中描述了斗兽场低层拱廊里潮湿凉爽，而顶部几层干燥温暖。
Exactly. And he told me about all the different plants that this guy Richard Nican found. 56 varieties of grass and cypresses and hollies. And yeah, just a real incredible variety. And what comes out of Deacon's book is that it's incredibly poetic description of this crumbling landscape that has become this kind of overgrown garden of great variety. It describes how it's damp and cool in the lower arcades of the Colosseum, but dry and
从而形成了这种不可思议的小气候，一个生命泛滥的生物穹顶。但你具体会发现，其中一些植物非常罕见，以至于它们实际上在西欧其他任何地方都没有出现过。于是迪肯坐下来，试图弄清楚这些植物是如何最终到达这个地方的，
warm on the top layers. As you get this incredible kind of micro climate, this biodome of overflowing life. But you find specifically that some of the plants were so rare that they didn't actually occur anywhere else in Western Europe. And so Deacon sits down and he tries to sort of work out how these plants ended up in this one spot
而这个标志性的文化场所简直是一个植物学奇迹。他提出了一个疯狂的假设。这些植物一定是被罗马人带进竞技场战斗的动物的皮毛甚至胃里带到斗兽场里的。罗马人带进狮子来与角斗士战斗，他们还带了长颈鹿和其他种类的非洲野生动物在斗兽场内进行仪式性的狩猎，其理论是，
and this iconic cultural spot is sort of a out how these plants ended up in this one spot and this like iconic cultural spot is sort of a botanical wonder. And he comes up with a kind of wild hypothesis. But these these plants must have been brought into the Colosseum on the fur or even in the stomachs of the animals that the Romans brought into the arena to fight. Romans brought in lions and they to fight gladiators and they brought in giraffes and other kinds of African wildlife for ceremonial hunts inside the Colosseum and the theory was,
正如植物所做的那样，搭乘在四处游荡的其他动物的背上，随着我们在世界各地移动，这可能是将这些植物带到斗兽场的原因。哦，太棒了。有点难以忍受。我确信一定是这样的。但这真是一个酷炫的故事。保罗·库珀非常喜欢这个意象。这种想法带有一种诗意，你知道，这些仪式性的动物狩猎，举办它们的目的是为了证明人类已经达到了这样的文明水平：
as plants do, traveling on the backs of other animals that move around, that we've moved around the world, that that might be the cause of what brought these plants to the Colosseum. Oh, that's so great. It's a little hard to bear. I'm sure that was. But it's a cool story. And Paul Cooper really likes this image. There's something poetic about the idea that, you know, these ritual animal hunts, that they were held as a way of proving that humans had reached a level of civilization
他们现在对动物拥有了完全的统治权。我们已经证明我们战胜了自然世界野蛮和破坏性的本质，但埋藏在这些动物的皮毛和内脏中的，是这些最终将侵入并爬满整个宏伟废墟的天然种子。那么，这个郁郁葱葱的小气候、几乎是温室的地方，是怎么变成我们今天所想的那种尘土飞扬的干燥废墟的呢？
that they now had complete dominion over the animals. And we'd shown that we triumped over the wild and destructive nature of the natural world, but the buried in the fur and guts of these animals were these natural seeds that were ultimately going to invade and climb over this whole magnificent ruin. So how did it happen that this, you know, verdant microclimate, almost greenhouse, become the dusty dry ruin that we think of today?
因此，在 1870 年，意大利在一个世俗民主政府的领导下实现了统一，他们接管了此前一直掌握在教皇手中的罗马城。这个新政府真正试图建立一种罗马，而此前罗马一直掌握在教皇手中。这个新政府真的在试图创造一种理性的、科学的、现代的意大利身份认同，但他们认为这深深植根于古罗马历史之中。因此，他们非常关心像斗兽场这样古老的这些废墟，并在这些建筑所代表的事物中投射出某种意大利特色。而这些植物与他们寻找的形象并不完全相符。他们将这些植物视为破坏废墟的入侵者，并开始
So in 1870, Italy gets unified under a secular democratic government, and they take control of the city of Rome, which had previously been in the hands of the papacy. And this new government is really trying to sort of create a sort of Rome, which had previously been in the hands of the papacy. And this new government is really trying to create a sort of rational, scientific, modern, Italian identity, but they see that as really rooted in this ancient Roman history. And so they care a lot about these old ruins like the Colosseum and projecting a certain Italianness to what these buildings represent. And the plants don't quite fit with the image that they're looking for. They see these plants as invaders that are damaging the ruins, and they begin to take
将植物从废墟上清除。甚至在当时，科学家和植物学界也遭到了一些真正的强烈反对，他们说，住手，这是一个充满所有这些完全独特植物物种的特殊微型生态系统。意大利植物学家兼伯爵夫人玛赞蒂（Mazzanti）说，大自然喜欢为古老的墙壁穿上富有诗意的外衣，而现在考古学的贪婪、考古学的贪婪摧毁了一切。因此，当时人们对此发出了一些抗议，但考古工作仍在继续，后来随着墨索里尼及其法西斯党统治的到来，废墟被完全剥离和发掘，彻底清理干净了，在我看来，
the plants off the ruins. And even at the time, there's some real pushback from scientists, from the botanical community who say, stop, this is this like special micro ecosystem filled with all these totally unique plant species. At Italian botanist and Countess, Mazzanti says that nature like to dress poetically the venerable walls and now archaeological cupidity, archaeological greed has destroyed everything. So people were giving a bit of an outcry about this at the time, but the archaeology went ahead and later on as you get into the rule of Mussolini and his fascist party, the ruin was completely stripped and excavated, completely cleaned, which is, in my view,
不幸的是，这就是我们今天看到的状况。所以这其实取决于你认为什么是正确的保护方式。我的意思是，你要保护吗？因为这确实是真的。藤蔓正在摧毁废墟。没错。这有一定的道理。这确实有道理。
unfortunately, the state we find in today. So it's really about whatever you think is the proper thing to preserve. I mean, do you preserve? I mean, because it is true. The vines were destroying the room. Right. There's a certain truth to that. There is truth to that.
但清除所有藤蔓的代价是什么？其中蕴含的历史以及那里事物的自然历史又是什么？没错。绝对是的。我想库珀说过，当他看到这些美丽的斗兽场画作时，这些可能搭乘狮子背部来到这里的珍贵植物，引发了一些有趣的问题：我们应该以什么状态来保护一座废墟？难道只有石头才是我们唯一关心的事情吗？
But what is the cost of removing all the vines and what is the history represented in the natural history of the things that are there? Right. Exactly. And I think Cooper says that when he sees these beautiful paintings of the Colosseum, these rare plants that traveled there potentially on the backs of lions, it raises some interesting questions about what state we should preserve a ruin in. Is it just the rocks that the only thing that we care about?
是的，可能还有一些故事隐藏在现有事物的其他方面中，这些方面讲述了历史的重要部分。是的，想到我们失去了这个由绿植覆盖的不可思议废墟的浪漫潜能，确实让我感到难过。还有这样一个事实，你知道，这些不同历史层叠中隐藏着被掩埋的故事。我也身处其中，诸如特定废墟中生长的植物等无形元素，可以讲述故事的绝大部分。所以与保罗交谈，看到他拼凑并在后来变成一篇文章的推特帖子，真的让我开始思考历史保护和建筑保护，
And yeah, that there are stories embedded potentially within other aspects of what's there that tell important parts of the history. Yeah, it does make me sad to think that we've lost the romantic potential of this site of this incredible ruin overgrown with greenery. And also the fact that, you know, there are buried stories hidden in these different layers of history. I'm also in the intangible elements like the floor are growing in a particular ruin can tell like a huge part of the story. So talking to Paul and you know seeing that the Twitter thread that he put together and then later turned into an article it really just made me think about historical preservation and arch- and
以及考古保护，到底什么才能成为长存事物的一部分，以及我们选择留下什么，什么又未能入选。没错。在这个案例中，这些植物全都没能入选。我的意思是，建筑世界的历史不仅仅是我们建造的东西，它还包括周围的一切，它可能是它所影响的自然动植物。这是一件了不起的事情。
archeological preservation and really what gets to be a part of what lives on and what we choose not to leave, what doesn't make the cut. Right. Which in this case is all these plants. I mean, the story of the built world is not just the things we build, it's all the stuff around it, and it could be the natural flora and fauna that it affects. And that's an amazing thing.
是的。斗兽场和其他地方仍然有一些植物，你知道，有人在决定该挑选什么，该拔除什么。现在这片空间周围已经建起了一座完整的城市。因此，它在其余的人造环境中显得更加格格不入。这是灰色的混凝土世界中的一抹绿色。不久前，99PI 的数字总监科尔斯泰特（Kohlstedt）开始研究一个关于面粉袋连衣裙的故事。这是一种用废旧面粉
Yeah. And there are still some plants in the Colosseum and other know, there are people that make decisions about what to pick and what to weed out. And now there's this whole city that's built up around this space. And so it's even more kind of outliers within the rest of the built environment. It's a little bit of greenery in a gray concrete world. So a while back 99PI's digital director, Kohlstedt, started researching a story about sack cloth dresses. It's a type of DIY clothing made from upcycled flour
和饲料袋改造而成的 DIY 服装。有一段时间我们考虑把它做成完整的一集节目，但库尔特与这个故事有着某种联系，这让它作为迷你故事变得更棒了。自制面粉袋服装在大萧条时期变得非常流行。但当我深入研究它时，我发现这个想法不知为何看起来很眼熟。
and feed sacks. And we considered it for a full episode for a while, but Kurt had a connection to the story that made it even better as a mini story. Homemade sack cloth apparel grew really popular during the Great Depression. But as I was looking into it, I thought the idea seemed familiar somehow.
所以我打电话给我认识的一位历史学家，看看她在我还小的时候是否跟我讲过这些。好吧，妈妈，你能简单介绍一下你自己以及你是做什么的吗？我是莎莉·格里尼-科尔斯泰特（Sally Grinage-Kohlstedt）。我是明尼苏达大学的教授，我在那里教授科学与美国文化课程，
So I called up this historian I know to see if maybe she had told me about them when I was a bit younger. Okay, so, mom, can you tell us briefly who you are and what you do? I'm Sally Grigney-Colstead. I'm a professor at the University of Minnesota, where I teach courses on science and American culture,
还有关于女性与性别以及科学的课程。所以我妈妈是在二战期间在密歇根州出生的，当时她父亲在底特律工作。我刚一出生，我父亲就被派往海外，所以我回家和她家人一起住在密歇根州芒姆（Thumb）的一个农场里。所以就像所有密歇根人一样，
and also courses on women and gender and science. So my mom was born in Michigan during World War II, and her dad worked in Detroit at the time. As soon as I was born, my father was shipped overseas, and so I went home to live with her family on a farm in the thumb of Michigan. So like all people from Michigan,
她把密歇根的形状比作戴着手套的手，并称之为“姆姆”（大拇指）或者它在手上的位置，对吧？是的，所以如果人们试图告诉你他们来自密歇根的什么地方，他们就会举起手来，指向那部分。就像美国的其他地方一样，密歇根人在 20 世纪 20 年代末和整个二战期间也想出了应对物资短缺的方法。嗯，自我还是个小女孩的时候起，我祖母就为我们所有人做大部分的缝纫。所以她用来做我们所谓的日常连衣裙的面料实际上是
she refers to the shape of Michigan as looking like a gloved hand, and refers to it as the thumb or where it is in the hand, right? Yeah, and so people if they're trying to tell you where they are from in Michigan, they'll just hold up their hand and like point to part of that. And like other places in America, people in Michigan had developed ways to deal with shortages in the late 1920s and going through World War II. Well, when I was a little girl, my grandmother did most of the sewing for all of us. And so the fabric that she used for what we're called her in-ray day dress was actually
她去当地杂货店挑选的面料。所以我的曾祖母会买面粉袋，然后重复使用这些面粉袋。然后面粉袋就成了这些连衣裙的面料。我的意思是，这种面料，我脑海中浮现的是装大米之类的袋子，那是糟糕的麻袋风格的袋子，这种面料到底是什么样的？嗯，实际上它必须织得很细，因为它是用来装面粉的。哦，对，我想这说得通。这是一种纯棉的面料。这是一种质量相当不错的面料。
fabric that she would pick out by going to the local general store. So my great grandmother would buy saxophower and then reuse those sax. And the flower sax became then the fabric for these dresses. I mean, was the fabric any, I think I picture the sex that hold rice or something, which are terrible burlap style sex, like what was the fabric like? Well, it actually had to be pretty finely woven because it was made to hold flour. Oh, yeah, I guess that makes sense. It was an all cotton kind of fabric. It's a really decent quality of fabric.
所以现在我们认为面粉是用这些较小的、五到十磅重的袋子装着的，通常是用纸做的。但当年情况则完全不同。有巨大的袋子，我记得它们和我一样大，因为我有整整 50 或 100 磅的面粉。那么面粉公司知道人们在使用他们的面粉袋并将其改造成连衣裙吗？是的，我的意思是，随着时间的推移，他们开始注意到这一点，并开始相应地调整他们的
So these days we think of flour as being something that comes in these smaller, five or ten pound bags, often made of paper. But back then it was a different story. There were huge sacks, and I remember they were as big as I was because I had the whole 50 or 100 pounds of flower. So did the flower companies know that people were using their flower sacs and upscaling them as dresses? Yeah, I mean, they started to figure this out over time and they started to adjust their
设计。因此，其中一些公司实际上使用了可以洗掉的墨水，这样你就能得到一块干净的白色布料。另一些公司则反其道而行之，设计了这些图案，所以你会买到印有舞者、骑师、小兔子、花朵或其他有趣东西的面粉袋。我妈妈的祖母会仔细挑选这些选项，并把最喜欢的带回家。
designs accordingly. And so some of them actually used ink that would wash back out so you could have this clean, white cloth. And others went the other direction with it and they designed these patterns and so you'd buy flower sacs with dancers or jockeys or bunnies or flowers or other interesting things. And my mom's grandmother would see through those options and bring home favorites from the store.
她很快了解到我不喜欢粉红色。所以我想她避免给我买粉红色的布料或布料上有粉红色花朵的东西，因为她知道我喜欢什么。当时的人们还把麻袋做成被子、窗帘，甚至尿布。农民们也会重复使用牲畜饲料袋。那种面料比较粗糙，但仍然可以用来做毛巾之类То.所以我的第一次缝纫经历就是拿一块那种面料并修剪它，
She learned quickly that I didn't like pink. So I think she avoided getting me pink fabric or pink flowers on fabric because she knew what I liked. People at the time also turned sacks into quilts, curtains, even diapers. And farmers reused livestock feed bags too. And that fabric was rougher, but it still worked for things like towels. So my very first sewing experience was taking a piece of that fabric and trimming it
这样我们就可以把它用作洗碗巾。显然，我曾祖父有一个饲料袋围裙，是我曾祖母为他做的工作服，用来干非常非常脏的活，脏到甚至不能穿工作服去干。比如帮母牛接生。所以你会买一袋牛饲料，然后用那个袋子来帮母牛分娩。
so that we could use it for dish towels. Apparently, my great grandfather had a feedback apron, my great-grandmother made him for doing really really dirty work like two dirty even for work clothes For example helping out cows in labor So you'd buy so you'd buy a sack of feed for the cows and then you'd use that sack to help birth new cows.
这太疯狂了。这就是我的回忆。所以公司当然赶上了面粉袋面料的潮流，他们意识到可以通过更好的棉花以及一路上更新、更时尚的图案来促进销量。一些制造商甚至赞助了全国面粉袋连衣裙制作比赛。哇。
That's pretty crazy. That's what I recall. So companies of course caught on to the sack fabric trend and they realized they could boost their sales with nicer cotton and fresh and more sort of fashionable patterns along the way. And some manufacturers even sponsored national sack cloth dressmaking competitions. and fresh and more sort of fashionable patterns along the way. And some manufacturers even sponsored national sackcloth dressmaking competitions. Wow.
没错。作为一个历史学家，我现在回想起来，这真是非常聪明的营销。所以当我第一次跟我妈妈谈起这件事时，她实际上说了这句话，我很喜欢，它是生活面料的一部分，是乡村美国生活的一部分，这似乎真的很贴切。最终，这些设计不仅仅源于必需。对这些人来说，它们也关乎时尚和身份认同，我觉得这真的非常迷人。所以，一旦我长大，我就可以去面料店买天鹅绒、羊毛或亚麻布。但在这些农场社区的平凡生活中，去杂货店挑选面料
That's right. It was very clever marketing as I think about it as a historian. So the first time I talked to my mom about this, she actually said this quote that I really liked, that it was part of the quote, fabric of life, of living in rural America, which seemed, you know, really apt. Ultimately these designs, they evolved beyond just being born of necessity. They became about fashion and identity for these people too, which I think is really fascinating. And so, once I arrived, I could go to a fabric store and buy velvet, a wool, or linen. But woven into ordinary life in these farm communities was going to the general store picking out your fabrics
然后尽量不挑到和某个邻居可能一样的面料，是生活的一部分。因为无论如何，即使你穿着面粉袋做的裙子，你也想看起来很好，你也想表达自己，这是一个普遍的现象。在某些情况下，他们会买一批袋子带回家，同一家里的每个人都会穿
and then trying not to pick out the same fabric as some neighbor might have. Because no matter what, even if you're wearing a dress man, I have sack cloth, you want to look good, you want to have it express yourself, that's like a universal thing. In some cases they'd buy a batch of bags, bring them home, and everybody in the same family would be kind of wearing
同样图案的面粉袋衣服。你实际上可以通过他们穿的图案看出谁是哪家的人。就像格子呢，像苏格兰短裙一样。完全正确，完全正确。就像现代的苏格兰短裙一样。太酷了。这真的太棒了。我喜欢和你谈论这个。我喜欢我妈妈是个历史学家，而且对这些事情如此感兴趣。
the same patterns of sack loss. You could actually tell who was from what family by the patterns that they were wearing. Like a tartan, like a kilter. Exactly, exactly. Like a modern day kilter. That's so cool. This has been really great. I love talking to you about this. I love the fact that my mom's a historian, and it is just so interested in these things.
并且也有这些极好的个人历史。非常感谢妈妈，同意做这件事并跟我谈论这些。嗯，我认为 99% Invisible 太棒了，我很高兴能成为它的一部分。太棒了，妈妈。我很爱你，代我向爸爸问好，我们过会儿再聊，好吗？
And has these great sort of personal histories too. Thank you so much, Mom, for agreeing to do this and talking to me about this. Well, I think 99% of the visible is terrific, and I'm happy to be part of any part of it. That's so great, Mom. I love you a lot, give my best to dad, and I'll talk to you soon, okay?
好的，我也爱你，库尔特，拜拜。拜拜。哦，这是一段美妙的旅程。哦，我太喜欢了。艾弗里（Avery）帮我把这一切都安排好了，她当时说，好吧，你可以剪掉 C-Won 的任何部分，但你必须保留那个。你必须保留那个署名。这就是为什么她知道她在做什么，艾弗里。
Okay, I love you too, Kurt, bye-bye. Bye. Oh, it's a great journey. Oh, I love it. Avery, who helped me get set up with all this, she was like, okay, you can cut any part of the C-Won, but you've got to keep that. You've got to keep that sign off. That's why she knows what she's doing every.
好的。非常感谢。从今年年初开始，那些一直听到节目最后的敏锐听众们（你们是我最喜欢的书呆子，那些听到节目开头的书呆子），敏锐的听到节目最后的听众们，你们可能会注意到，自从我们开始使用所有原创音乐以来，出现了一个新的制作人员名单。既然你的声音已经录进去了，你为什么不自我介绍一下，以及你在节目里负责什么工作呢？我是肖恩·里亚尔（Sean Rial），我是节目的作曲，我负责所有的音乐。
Yeah. Alright, thanks so much. Since the beginning of the year, astute listeners who will listen all the way to the end of the show, you're my favorite nerds, the nerds who listen all the way to the beginning of the year, a stuute listeners who listen all the way to the end of the show, you're my favorite nerds, the nerds who listen all the way to the end of the show, you may have noticed a new production credit since we started using all original music. Since I've had your voice on here, why don't you actually introduce yourself and what you do at the show? I'm Sean Rial and I'm the composer for I do all the music.
酷。所以你有一个迷你故事。这是你的第一个迷你故事。这是我第一次制作广播故事。完全是第一次。好了。好吧，恭喜。那我们听听吧。
Cool. And so you have a mini story. This is your first mini story. It's my first radio story ever. At all. There we go. Okay, well, congratulations. So let's hear it.
那是 19 世纪末，人们才刚开始接触录制音乐。那时的录音过程有点忙乱，我想象其中应该有很多乐趣，但也可能更加忙乱。在他们使用麦克风和录音室之前，声音是通过这些大喇叭收集的，这些喇叭主要由黄铜或铜制成，这些录音喇叭会将声音振动收集并聚焦到一个小振膜上，振膜会使唱针振动，从而在蜡盘上刻出凹槽。我是不是应该把这些录音喇叭想象成基本上就像留声机一样，就像那种通过这些喇叭播放声音的老式留声机？
So it's the late 1800s and people are just starting to consume recorded music. And the process of recording at this time is kind of hectic, and I like to imagine a lot of fun, but maybe more hectic. So before they used microphones and studios, sound was captured by these big horns, which were made of like mainly brass or copper, and these recording horns would collect and focus the sound vibrations into this little diaphragm, and the diaphragm would vibrate a stylus that cut a groove into a wax disc. Should I be picturing these recording horns pretty much like a phonograph, like an old fashioned phonograph that plays out through one of these horns?
是的，这差不多是一回事，只不过是反过来的。好吧，酷。是的，所以，这就是其中一部分，正着和反着是一样的。但这个过程的问题在于，这些录音喇叭所能响应的声音频率是有限的。因此，某些乐器，比如也由黄铜制成的图巴号（大号）和法国号（圆号），
Yeah, it's like the same thing except just backwards. Okay, cool. Yeah, so yeah, that's like part of it is just same backwards as forwards. But the problem with this process was that these recording horns were limited in what sound frequencies they'd respond to. So certain instruments like tubas and French horns which were also made of brass
被录下来的声音会比吉他或小提琴等弦乐器大得多。这倒说得通。所以现在我们把每个乐器都在单独的轨道上录音，并在事后进行大量的电平调整，但当年他们必须用一个或有时两个（如果他们真的很讲究的话）这样的大录音喇叭，在一个房间里录制整个乐队。然后他们只需复制他们录制好的唱盘。没有后期剪辑。
will get picked up much louder than string instruments like guitars or violins. Or that makes sense. So nowadays we record every instrument on its own track and do a lot of leveling after the fact, but back then they had to record whole orchestras with just one or sometimes two, if they were really fancy, of these big recording horns in a single room. And then they just make copies of the disc that they recorded on. There was no editing.
如果圆号声音太大，或者歌剧演员用假声破坏了录音，你就把唱盘扔掉重来。因此，为了获得不同乐器和人声的平衡混音，音响工程师会把音乐家们安排在录音室的各个角落，距离录音喇叭有不同的远近。有时他们会让声音较大的乐器（如圆号）背对录音喇叭，面向后墙，而音乐家们则通过
If there was too much French horn or if an opera singer like, you know, blew out the recording with their falsetto, you throw the disc away and you do it again. So in order to get a balanced mix of different instruments and voices, sound engineers would arrange the musicians all around the studio at various distances from the recording horns. Sometimes they'd have the louder instruments, like French horns, pointed at the back wall away from the recording horn, and the musicians would be watching their conductor
镜子看着他们的指挥。哇。他们会把钢琴放在一个平台上，这样里面的琴槌和琴弦就会与录音喇叭对齐，这是我最喜欢的一个。有时他们会把歌手放在一个小推车上，这样助理就可以在较轻柔的人声乐段时把他们推近喇叭，而在响亮的乐段时把他们推开。
like in a mirror. Wow. And they put pianos on top of a platform so that the mallets and chords that are inside would be lined up with the recording horn, and this one's one of my favorites. They'd sometimes put a singer like on a little trolley so that an assistant could wheel them closer to the horn for quieter vocal passages and wheel them away during loud ones.
听起来很混乱，就像是鲁布·戈德堡式的乐队录音。太棒了。好的。但弦乐器是最难录制的。正因为如此，低音提琴的部分通常改用大号来演奏。而且许多工程师根本不想处理小提琴的录音。所以在某个时间之前，极少有带有小提琴的录音。真的吗？
That sounds chaotic, it's like a Rube Goburg recording of an orchestra. That's amazing. Okay. But the string instruments were the hardest to record. And because of that, like stand-up bass parts were often just played on tuba instead. And a lot of engineers didn't want to deal with recording violins at all. So there were very few recordings with violins on them before a certain time. Is that true?
嗯，实际上有相当数量的小提琴录音，但这部分是因为工程师们经历了所有这些麻烦来做这些精心制作的会话，但也因为这个。天哪。好吧，你能描述一下你手里拿的是什么吗？我手里拿着一把斯特罗小提琴（Astro violin），这是我的乐队成员在一个新奇乐器店里找到的，它有小提琴的琴颈、琴头、琴马和琴弦，但没有共鸣体，只有一个木棒，然后还有一个伸出来的大喇叭。所以想象一下一把没有……你叫什么来着，那个有……你知道的，就像我们认为的那样，当你拉小提琴时贴在你脖子上的那个共鸣体的琴。那些全都没有了。
Well, there were actually a fair amount of recordings with violins, but it was part because of the engineers going through all this trouble to do these elaborate sessions, but also because of this. Oh my God. OK, so could you describe what you're holding? I'm holding Astro violin, which my bandmate found at this novelty music shop, and it's got the neck
取而代之的是，基本上是一个喇叭坐在……你知道的，指向……你知道的，向后折叠进自身，声音从喇叭的末端传出来。就像录音就像是留声机的倒放一样。这也是留声机的相同概念。琴弦的振动进入这个位于琴马下方的振膜，
and head and bridge of a violin and the strings, but instead of a body, it's just got this wooden rod, and then this huge horn that's coming out of it. So imagine a violin with no, what do you call it the body that has the, you know, like we think of that resonates that goes up against your neck when you play a violin. That's all gone.
它振动声音，声音被喇叭投影出来。哇，太神奇了。它看起来真的很像，基本上会成为蒸汽朋克乐队的核心部件。是的，确实有蒸汽朋克乐队在使用这个。你想听听它听起来是什么样吗？我很想听。太棒了。在某种程度上，在它原本的状态下，在这个房间里，它听起来有点像老式的小提琴录音，因为它通过了那个振膜和喇叭，并且带有一点
And then instead is this, basically a trumpet sitting on, you know, pointed, you know, folded back into itself and the sound comes out of the end of the trumpet horn. Just like how recording was like the gramophone backwards. This is also the same concept of the gramophone. The vibrating of the strings goes into this diaphragm that's down here by the bridge
电声学的处理感觉。是的，这也是其中一部分，之所以以这种方式录制声音，是因为那是旧录音喇叭能够捕捉到的声音。没错。所以这个东西的作用其实就是放大录音喇叭能够捕捉到的频率。
and it vibrates the sound which gets projected out by the horn. Wow, that's amazing. It looks really, it would be the centerpiece of a steampunk orchestra basically. Yeah, there are there are steampunk bands that that use this You want to hear what it sounds like? I would love to That's awesome. In a way in its native state, like in this room, it kind of sounds like an old recording of a violin because it's going through that diaphragm and horn and it has a little bit
没错，所以在某种程度上，它是为了迎合正在录音的喇叭而设计的。就像它是另一侧的模拟匹配，以便让声音更好地被捕捉到。是的。它做的另一件事是，实际上，那个喇叭，它让声音更有方向性，因为所有这些音乐家都必须将他们的声音汇聚到房间角落里的这个声学喇叭中。当你能有一把小提琴将其声音直接指向喇叭，而不是像共鸣体通常那样向房间四周辐射时，这就非常有用了。
of a electroacoustic sort of seeming processing. Yeah, and that's part of it is that the reason why recording sound that way is because that's what the old recording horns were able to pick up. Right. And so what this was doing was it was actually just amplifying the frequencies that the recording horns would pick up.
一种电声学的处理方式。是的，这也是其中的一部分，之所以用这种方式录音，是因为那是旧式录音号角能够捕捉到的声音。没错。所以这个装置所做的，实际上只是放大了录音号角能够捕捉到的频率。
Right, so it was designed to speak to the horn that is doing the recording in some ways. Like it's the analog, the match on the other side of it to make it even better to be picked up. Yeah. Another thing that it did was it actually, like, the horn, it made the sound more directional because all of these musicians had to like funnel their sounds like into this like one acoustic horn in the corner of the room. It was really helpful when you could have a violin that would point it sound directly at the horn rather than just radiating out into the room, which is what the resonant body usually does.
没错，所以在某种程度上，它就是为了和负责录音的号角进行“对话”而设计的。就像是它的模拟匹配端，在另一端让声音更容易被捕捉到。是的。它做的另一件事是，就像那个号角一样，它让声音更具方向性，因为所有这些音乐人都必须将他们的声音汇聚到房间角落里的这个单一的声学号角中。如果你有一把小提琴，能把声音直接对准号角，而不是像共鸣体通常那样向房间四周辐射，这就非常有用了。
Oh, that's awesome. And for a little while, it was a big deal in the recording industry. These designs were applied to all kinds of instruments, drove guitars, drove cellos, drove mandalins, drove ukuleles, and actually a lot of instruments that weren't under the strobe name, but there were just a lot of different instruments from different companies that utilize this design. And strobe is the brand name. Yeah, strobe is the name of the person
哦，太棒了。在有一段时间里，它在录音界是个了不起的大事。这些设计被应用到各种乐器上，包括吉他、大提琴、曼陀林、尤克里里，实际上还有很多并非以 Stroh 命名的乐器，只是有许多来自不同公司的不同乐器都采用了这种设计。Stroh 是品牌名称。是的，Stroh 是发明第一台这种乐器的人的名字，
who invented the first one. He was John Matthias Augustus Stroh. And so were they all manufactured by a company that was the Stroh Company? Or was it just a design that was used by anybody? Yeah, I was the Stroh Violin Company and they kept manufacturing them even past Stroh's death in 1914. His son picked up where he left off. There were a lot of articles that were speculating about where it fit into the broader world of music. Like this one in Strand Magazine from 1902 that I found that was pushing hard that these
他叫约翰·马蒂亚斯·奥古斯塔斯·斯特罗（John Matthias Augustus Stroh）。那么它们都是由斯特罗公司生产的吗？还是说这只是任何人都可以使用的设计？是的，这就是斯特罗小提琴公司，他们在 1914 年斯特罗去世后仍然继续生产。他的儿子继承了他的衣钵。当时有很多文章都在猜测它在更广阔的音乐世界中的定位。就像我在 1902 年的《斯特兰杂志》（Strand Magazine）上找到的这篇一样，它极力宣称这些
instruments were the future. The harmonics are loud and pure, but what is of great importance is an entire absence of scrape. This is a point that solo players will value highly. Of course, the idea of a new violin that can be played upon immediately is finished, and that will produce marvelous tone and quality of sound will possibly come as a shock to old-fashioned people during the original violin has been a cherished idol, but the spirit of invention respects no one's prejudices. And those are actually phonophiddles playing underneath, which are kind of a relative to
乐器代表了未来。泛音响亮而纯净，但最重要的是完全没有摩擦杂音。这是独奏者会高度重视的一点。当然，那种一弹就能发出美妙音色和质感的新式小提琴的出现，可能会给那些将原版小提琴视为挚爱偶像的保守派带来冲击，但发明精神不尊重任何人的偏见。而刚才在背景里演奏的其实是单弦琴（phonofiddle），它们算是
the strobe island. That's awesome. So I say you have one, but what happened to these instruments in the larger world? So around 1925, electric microphone technology made its way into recording studios and broader ranges of instruments became more possible to capture. So these modified instruments no longer like, you know, made the same practical sense of recording industry. So the Strav Island company slowed production and then finally shut down in 1942.
斯特罗小提琴的亲戚。太棒了。所以我说你有一把，但在更广阔的世界上，这些乐器后来怎么样了？大约在 1925 年，电容麦克风技术进入了录音室，更多种类的乐器得以被收录。因此，这些改良乐器在录音界不再具有以往那样的实际意义。于是斯特罗小提琴公司减缓了生产，并最终在 1942 年关门大吉。
You tell them sad about it. I can't tell. And a lot of people write about them is kind of like the silly flash in the pan thing, but they were a really valuable tool for the beginnings of the recording industry. And without them, there are a lot of records where violins, like, wouldn't have been as present probably. Or studios just like wouldn't have bothered to record them at all. So after they weren't necessary
你看上去挺难过的。我一眼就能看出来。很多人把它们写成一种愚蠢的、昙花一现的事物，但它们确实是录音产业初期极其宝贵的工具。如果没有它们，许多唱片里的提琴声可能就不会那么突出，或者录音室根本懒得去录制它们。那么在它们不再必要
because recording technology had advanced, did they just kind of fizzle out as an instrument? Well, they're actually still around. Oh, like you can find them in wide use and folk music from Romania or Myanmar. Shakira, you had a Strow violin player as part of her 2010-2011 tour. And resonator guitars, you know, those ones
因为录音技术进步之后，它们作为乐器是不是就逐渐消亡了呢？嗯，其实它们现在还在。哦，比如你可以在罗马尼亚或缅甸的民间音乐中广泛地找到它们。夏奇拉（Shakira）在 2010 到 2011 年的巡演中，就有一位斯特罗小提琴乐手作为她乐队的一部分。还有共鸣箱吉他，你知道的，就是那种
with like the partly metal bodies and they got kind of like the nice designs like that into that. Yeah, totally. So those are the same technology as the Strobe Island. And one of the inventors of the resonator guitar had visited the Strobe factory like in its heyday. And there are a number of articles that say
部分采用金属琴身、上面有很好看的设计的那些吉他。是的，完全正确。所以它们和斯特罗小提琴使用的是同一种技术。共鸣箱吉他的发明者之一曾在其鼎盛时期参观过斯特罗工厂，有许多文章都说
that he based his designs off what he saw there. So it still lives on to this day. And what is it that you, I mean you said you're a little sad about it, but why are you sad? What does it do for you? What do you enjoy about it? Well, I think what I feel sad about is that it's just so different than a violin. And the strand magazine article was trying to be like, this is better than the violin. And of course, you know, like, violins, which had been around for a long time to be like, this is like better than the violin. And of course, you know, like violins which have been around,
他是根据在那里看到的设计来创作自己的作品的。所以它至今仍然存在。你刚才说你觉得有点难过，到底是因为什么让你难过？它对你有什么意义？你喜欢它的什么？嗯，我觉得难过的是，它和普通小提琴实在太不一样了。《斯特兰杂志》的那篇文章曾试图宣称“这比小提琴更好”。当然，你知道的，对于存在了很长时间的普通小提琴来说，
had been around for a long time are like, no better than a violin. I mean, it's actually kind of a little bit more limited range by definition than a violin, but it has a really kind of, there's something nice about that sound. Yeah, it's a different kind of range of frequencies. I don't know, I just think that like it's wonderful to have like different kinds of sounds. Right. So yeah. Cool. Well thanks for introducing us to the Strove Island. That's amazing. Thank you, Romain. We're going to take a quick break and I'll catch you up on a couple notable stories in the
经历很长时间后会觉得“这可没比小提琴好”。我的意思是，从定义上讲，它的音域实际上比小提琴还要更局限一点，但它有一种非常独特的音色，那种声音真的很美妙。是的，那是另一种不同的频率范围。我不知道，我只是觉得拥有不同种类的声音是一件很棒的事。对吧。所以，是的。太酷了。谢谢你向我们介绍斯特罗小提琴。太神奇了。谢谢你，罗曼。我们要稍事休息，稍后我会为你盘点几个引人注目的故事，
flurry of flag redesigns that were catalyzed by the TED Talk I gave a couple years back. Stay tuned. So in March of 2015, I did a main stage TED Talk where I talked about the design of flags and how many city flags around the country were particularly awful. And I performed it live, like a live podcast on the TED stage. And I used the voice of Vexelon Eric extraordinaire Ted K to explain his flag design principles and it was a total blast and What's great is that since then there have been over a hundred flag redesigns in the US And it's been fun to watch people engage with their civic symbols in a new way
这些故事是由我几年前做过的一场 TED 演讲催生的国旗重新设计热潮。请继续收听。所以在 2015 年 3 月，我在 TED 主舞台上做了一场演讲，谈论了旗帜设计以及全国有多少城市的旗帜实在太糟糕了。我是现场表演的，就像在 TED 舞台上做一场现场播客一样。我借用了旗帜学专家泰德·K（Ted K）的声音来解释他的旗帜设计原则，这真是太棒了。最棒的是，自那以后，美国已经有了一百多个旗帜重新设计案例，看着人们以全新方式与他们的公民标志互动，真的很有趣。
Burlington Vermont had an open call flag redesign contest to replace their coat of arm style flag And the competition was won by twin 12-year-old brothers, Owen and Lucas Martiso. It's a white, green, and white zigzag stripe on a blue field. It's a very handsome flag. Congrats, guys. A particular note in the flagry design world
佛蒙特州伯灵顿市举行了一场公开征集的旗帜重新设计比赛，以取代他们带有纹章风格的旗帜。比赛的优胜者是 12 岁的双胞胎兄弟欧文（Owen）和卢卡斯·马蒂索（Lucas Martiso）。这是一个在蓝色底布上有白色、绿色、白色之字形条纹的旗帜。这是一面非常漂亮的旗帜。祝贺你们，小伙子们。旗帜设计界特别值得注意的一个案例
is the flag of Pocahtello, Idaho. Pocahtello was voted the worst city flag in North America by the members of the North American Vexelological Association, and it was kind of the punchline of the TED Talk. And after they heard about the talk, they invited me up to Pocotello to spur their flag redesign efforts. And they couldn't have been nicer and more gracious at a fantastic time there.
是爱达荷州波卡特洛（Pocattello）市的旗帜。波卡特洛被北美旗帜学协会的成员评为北美最差的城市旗帜，它也成了那场 TED 演讲中的笑料。在他们听说这个演讲后，他们邀请我去波卡特洛，以推动他们的旗帜重新设计工作。他们表现得无比友善和热情，我在那儿度过了一段美妙的时光。
I had breakfast with the mayor. CBS Sunday morning came to Pocotello to do a national news piece about their redesign. And I think, even though, you know though I was having a little fun with them, the city came away from the experience really excited and enjoyed the attention. And best of all, after our year-long effort, they got a new beautiful flag. The new flag is called mountains left and it has three red peaks symbolizing three local mountains on a field of blue and a blue line at the bottom that represents the port enough river and at the top of the highest peak is a golden compass rose representing Poca de la Transportation History.
我和市长一起吃早餐。CBS《星期日早晨》节目来到波卡特洛，制作了一篇关于他们重新设计旗帜的国家新闻报道。我想，尽管我在他们身上开了一点玩笑，但这个城市从这段经历中获得了极大的兴奋，并享受了这种关注。最棒的是，经过我们一年的努力，他们获得了一面美丽的新旗帜。新旗帜被称为“左侧群山”，上面有三个代表当地三座山峰的红色山峰，底部的蓝色线条代表波特纳夫河（Portneuf River），在最高峰的顶部是一个金色的罗盘玫瑰，代表波卡特洛的交通历史。
It is a fine flag. I hope to see it everywhere next time I'm up there. If you're curious to see a picture of it, Google, it's 2017, just like you use your phone. But we'll also have a picture of it on our website at 99pi.org. Well done, Poca de la. It was a real honor to be your guest.
这是一面很棒的旗帜。下次我再去那里时，希望能到处看到它。如果你好奇想看看它的照片，用谷歌搜一下，现在是 2017 年了，就像你平时用手机一样。不过我们的网站 99pi.org 上也会有它的照片。干得好，波卡特洛。能做你们的嘉宾真是莫大的荣幸。
We're going to take a little break until 2018, but I'm going to put some surprise 99pi stories on the feet that I know you'll dig, so you might not even notice we're going. Have a happy new year. We'll be back in 2018 with another mini-stories installment featuring the rest of the crew and a couple of this new suggested stories as well. See you then. 99% of visible is Avery Trollfmann, Emmith Fitzgerald, Sharif Yusuf, Delaney Hall,
我们要稍微休息一下直到 2018 年，但我会在节目源里放一些惊喜的 99pi 故事，我知道你们会喜欢的，所以你们甚至可能都不会注意到我们离开了。祝大家新年快乐。我们将在 2018 年带着另一个迷你故事系列回归，其中包含其余的工作人员以及几个新建议的故事。到时候见。99% Invisible 的成员有埃弗里·特鲁夫曼（Avery Truffman）、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、谢里夫·优素福（Sharif Yusuf）、德兰尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）、
Taren Mazza, composer Sean Rial, senior producer Katie Mingle, digital director Kurt Colstead, and me, Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7K ALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. We are a part of Radio Topia from PRX, a collective of the best most innovative shows in all of podcasting. We are supported by the Knight Foundation and sticker-loving listeners, just like you.
塔伦·马扎（Taren Mazza）、作曲家肖恩·里亚尔（Sean Rial）、高级制作人凯蒂·明格尔（Katie Mingle）、数字总监库尔特·科尔斯特ッド（Kurt Colstead），以及我，罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。我们是旧金山 91.7 KALW 的一个项目，在加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的市中心电台街（Radio Row）制作。我们是 PRX 旗下 Radiotopia 的一部分，这是一个汇集了播客界最优秀、最具创新性节目的联盟。我们由奈特基金会（Knight Foundation）和像你这样热爱贴纸的听众共同支持。
You can find 99% invisible and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI Ork or on Instagram Tumblr and Reddit too. But the real 99PI HQ is at 99PI dot org. Radio TepiRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在 Facebook 上找到 99% Invisible 并参与关于节目的讨论。你可以在 Twitter 上@我 @Roman Mars，也可以@节目 @99PIOrg，或者在 Instagram、Tumblr 和 Reddit 上找到我们。不过真正的 99PI 总部是在 99PI 点 org。Radiotopia 从 PRX。这个单集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。